do you remember the first time you saw a
dinosaur
life finds a way
[Music]
do you remember the first time you saw a
dinosaur for kids who grow up loving
dinosaurs the Jurassic movies are really
the vehicle for them to see their dreams
realize the Jurassic movies have always
been suspenseful and exciting we're
telling the next chapter this story
takes dinosaurs and takes Jurassic where
it's never gone before we're literally
blowing up the island
in this movie we have a new director
Juan Antonio Bayona I love playing with
suspense
I like intensity and I love to make the
audience feel the total experience he's
genius when it comes to frightening
people careful dinosaurs everywhere and
they're flipping out and killing people
let's go it was important to us that the
story be balanced on the characters some
of whom we know and some of whom were
just meeting Jeff Goldblum I'm not gonna
lie that's pretty awesome if I'm talking
about dinosaurs again in this Jurassic
world you will see more dinosaurs than
you've ever seen before
on this movie we are dealing with real
animatronic dinosaurs it looks like a
real dinosaur I couldn't help to freak
out the entire time the challenge of
making a secret is finding the right
balance between what people aren't
expecting and what people will be
surprised by
this movie is different it's gonna be
intense and pretty spectacular
[Music]
that was my best acting
it's like nothing you've ever seen
before
man it's Jurassic
this is gonna be awesome
[Music]